the comedy sir would like you to know
that the views and opinions expressed on
this podcast are strictly those of the
speakers or authors and do not
necessarily reflect or represent the
views and opinions held by the Comedy
Store and its affiliates
[Music]
but that's not the rule yeah but it's
not even credit so even really so it's
like I don't know what the pluggable
well I think he's in a subject position
should we start the Pelican or you don't
okay whatever is it on yeah it's been on
oh are we allowed to talk about this or
no I don't I love them and I think they
cause ative things for the store I think
the store is in a better place
financially and also viol eyes I mean
the lineups on here are the best in the
world
yeah yeah and there was a time when I
was working for Mitzi that we were
literally one if she missed one payment
the bank owned this place yes so yeah
he'll be back yeah hello its
infrastructure like it's ridiculous but
his job he has to keep asses in the
seats or he doesn't make a certain
amount yeah so yeah if he can call his
friends that may or may not really be
comics yeah yeah
somebody made a great point the other
night like and it was mo mandel who I
love
he said it was packed it was Monday I
was like let's everybody doing here
Monday Monday's usually relaxed night
you call me work out it was jam-packed
couldn't even get in the parking lot and
it's because everybody was there was a
belly room show David Spade and Friends
there was a big show in the main room
people I've never heard of but Netflix
is giving out specials and giving you
like a million to you know a few million
dollars to do a special and if you're
Rob Schneider David spit why wouldn't
you jump on that yeah that's what
they're doing yeah
and so everybody's coming to see them
because they're great in their movies I
wouldn't necessarily call them stand up
stand up
yeah they they do great and they put
asses in the seats no I'm not no no I
know I I was freaked out when I was here
the other night was like yeah oh man
Dale said that he goes because of
Netflix it's Netflix assault that's
hilarious
Tommy used to before he moved away when
would yell at me about how dumb it was
that David Spade was here he was so bad
like that was the one that got him in
one
David Spade yeah one you don't you know
work there anymore so I don't know why
it's we it doesn't reach our demographic
yeah I like David I like though some of
those guys I mean I think that they put
their time and obviously I believe that
here though not here but there hi it's
weird but they have riot yeah I would
never take it away from them right I
still don't think that guys that started
here should have preference yeah is that
right reward money yeah yeah and is he
working here was hell on our salute yeah
hell on earth
no years yeah especially when the club
didn't do much for you Ryu gave you
stage time when there was an industry
that was erratic stage time right we
didn't even get paid a legal wage I know
we did I got 425 a night I know and I do
like a nine-hour shift and well Dean
would still cut hours off my whole did I
on the roof yeah I had to [ __ ] sleep
too [ __ ] late Dennis what the broke
in like 20 years
Polly gotta go up they did right up
there like this raining and I'm like I
was side yeah sister so close yeah it
was awful I remember one of my first
paid regular spots and I've heard so
many people tell the same story I was
excited I actually got up before
midnight or something yeah that was
young it was like oh this is great I was
working the back door anyway I got off
stage and there me like well you gotta
go clean up the puke yeah went straight
to cleaning up some chicks puke all over
the hallway in the door like she almost
made it to the bathroom in the hallway
but didn't quite get there and just
spray down the wheels head shot next to
the bathroom that's disgust and then I
just sat there muffling but we're better
off than some people yeah like I'll bet
a med yeah never worked here yes she
just she truly can't gets much here
anymore
yeah he's getting spots well he was
fighting yeah he cared at the pie hole
threatened the talent coordinator
and I loved Ahmed and I agree that he
you know he's always been a great dude
to me but I mean I'm smart enough to
know that if I start calling the phone
guys and telling them all to tell the
talent coordinator that I'm going to sue
the club
yeah giving me my rightful spot yeah
we're not going to get spots yeah
oh there's another paid regular decent
comic that that was fighting with Adam
right now and he's like he's like all
he's like I will figure it out but he's
not threatening anything wrong he's like
chill about it he's like I got a you
know another hurdle I don't want to know
the name but let me ask you this is this
comic good okay is he a store like yes
sure sir guy yeah and he does he have
[ __ ] going on other things that kind of
a kind of okay yeah decent stuff you
should get spots yeah yes but it's like
instead of calling and arguing with
because here the baby is okay if you if
you go to an audition in the casting
agent and they don't book you do you go
back and yell the casting agent no no
we're talking about Mike right yes
that's so funny a vermin no no young
yeah my god yeah yeah yeah he does every
great Oh somebody is so mellow about it
he's like he's got through doesn't argue
with him either just another obstacle
will do it yeah but he is one of us no
he is one of us he ever 100% he is and
he has an army yes
he has worked more on like film and
things like that producing and writing
yeah not stand-up so that's why I say oh
yeah but you still opens for Saget and
[ __ ] on the road he's offered me a cup
under time huge he was on the road with
Logan yeah but he's also the first guy
to ever go hey pick me I said one night
I met in Silver Lake it was like 3:00 in
the morning I'm sleeping
this is what I used to live there
because oh my god it's Mike what he's
like I don't know what my car is I love
him I go oh are you drunk he goes I'm
drunk with my car I'm sleeping not even
for uber I need you to pick me up I'm
scared he's on vine oh my I get on my
car I pick him up then he goes I know
where my car is
can you drive into my car so we're
driving through the hills and then we go
to this gigantic mansion we pull in a
little suckle in here he goes Tobey
Maguire knew you were gonna say right I
go Oh Danny gets out of the cup and he
looks at me he goes you what they said
that you can come in I go who Tobey
Mark Wahlberg yeah and Leonardo DiCaprio
weird you cruisin just by themselves
let's just say I looked at him I go nope
sorry dude Benito wisely because back
then I thought that there was a gay
thing going on and yet DiCaprio's or
like spider-man tickets in front of my
face right I have to suck it you'd have
to same so I get it yeah yeah so I never
did but like and that's happened a
couple of the other night that happened
to he goes drive me to this club
who's in there leo come on in yeah nope
no but he has all those guys don't his
friends yeah no those are yeah that's
great your group yeah
with Toby all that all those guys yes
yeah camp Rio goes like Titanic I mean
he's like I want to sketch you and then
you have to lay down yeah yeah he is the
number one guy I don't put myself in the
situation yeah makes sense but my agent
goes now work no I don't want to do it
yeah not I want to do it oh yeah Mexican
accent thank you but uh yeah he he
should because of the history but I
agree I I'm for him I'm all for him but
it's just a funny he graduated x2 he was
all Melbourne yeah they said I run the
light and I was like well they do keep
track of that he's like I'll run the
light and my mind like all you did when
he was on our podcast let's talk about
how he always runs the life I haven't
run the light in 20 years yeah and I was
like wait a minute
two months ago you said that that's your
thing you always run the line the other
guys produced so many movies and stuff
yes way trick night was that a [ __ ]
tricky pull last week what what
a couple years ago what I do this
[ __ ] loosey-goosey comes up to me a
stop pointing so what I do
moody says hi no no he was asking about
here I think you said something like she
wanted to hire so remember you all is
that what you say that's all I think I
tell you he remembers you know I'm like
oh [ __ ] you remember me was it that Paul
Mooney was here one not cool have a big
fan yeah yeah I'm a big fan huge fan he
is a less super-talent incredibly creepy
he was he was mean to these guys because
they were dork like when I said I was
going to try to get him on the podcast
everybody wrote me immediately like a
couple other door guys finish O'Neill
they're like ask him why he spit on me
ask him why he did it
Azen what because he was kind of mean to
the door guys he called me one night and
left a message saying I hang out with
the white Devils I think I was the white
devil buddy I don't you know right yeah
yesyes with that guy I remember one eye
when I opened for you at Caroline's he
was doing the Late Show out that time
and then he kept he was just kind of
rude general yeah in general but yeah I
did watch him call out Johnny's app one
night only on all this [ __ ] and that
was one of the funniest things I've ever
seen
yeah you need to quit tell people you
know Richard pride you knew Richard
Pryor the same way you don't need people
you bothered Richard Pryor loved it so I
go back down did he remember because I
look at him and I put my hand on the
shoulder Paul what's up because I think
I remember you Wow it broke my foot like
there's the things my I thought if he
saw you he'd remember like oh this guy
but he is in and out I think of what I
think he has early stages well the next
time [ __ ] tell me that I don't know
a medical condition
I thought you fell oh you need to go say
hi okay do we have to go backwards in
this podcast why do you still feel like
everyone's against you I'm not against
how I live that was born
well I'm sickening let it go alright not
out to get you I could give two [ __ ]
if you
right now the reason we had you back on
is one people loved it our pen I thought
we never really interviewed yeah a
battle whatever it has the Godfather of
modern comedy store it is true was a dad
I was saying man we've named you that
uh-huh you are it nobody would let him
finish his sentence oh my god
you are responsible for I would say 65%
of the the comics that perform at this
club at least that's a good thing a
majority of the time whenever someone I
always go and Bobby Lee helped me get in
yeah Bobby Lee recognized me
that must be the nicest comic in the
world
I've only people I remember is Brody
Brody here you know I convinced Kevin
Christie to stand up and so I walked him
through that stuff yep
other than that I mean I mean I've heard
that before but it's like maybe I'm not
one of those guys that says like don't
do it right right I feel like everyone
should try it if they want to do it a
lot of these like people I think who are
already doing comedy but you just helped
him get in here and I do that I get
things like what what I did was and our
mission cases which I which I showcased
a bunch of people but I also got a lot
of people signed to this agency that I
was a part of aqua yeah
so I'm re Shaffir yeah my black a bunch
of kids yeah it didn't have agents i
facilitated that but the reason why I
did that though was it because I'm a
good person okay was because I read a
book it's the [ __ ] Karma think it's
this seven spiritual laws of success
it's said in that book you have to help
other people achieve success okay so I
just started doing that so I hope you
will get well I know I just thought you
know what I'm I think about me way too
much okay maybe they're right maybe I
should get out of my supposed to be
selflessly not selfishly right I don't
you mean by that what you're saying that
I know I mean I did it like a jealous
act I tried it might work they were yeah
I tried to do it that way because they
got handed down I got
crow because of re so and I re got me in
so I see yeah so you still you started
to snowball I want so I try to go here
mmm great time books two out of the
three commercial right now and they
haven't sent me on an audition since I
booked the set the Geico spot you but
you go out for a lot of commercial stop
I don't do anyone you just don't go or
you don't get auditions for it I don't
think you go out I just won't do I just
don't do it I mean I just not enough for
me to do it because I mean I got this is
II show got picked up which is awesome
but I didn't read for that either right
we just have to do it offer yeah and I'm
doing this vise line show it's an offer
I just did a you know cat damn so I just
here's the thing is I'm not going to the
last pilot season I signed up I memorize
my lines I went in positive and I didn't
really get anything right and it's been
like that for a couple years was just
like I tested for a couple things and I
was this year I was just like I don't
want to do it next year I'm making
enough money on the road i which is god
bless the road right and then I guess I
was on love on the judge here you know
that I love so I did a couple of us
those of that and then it deceased this
year's just been incredible my name of
the pilot the ABC pilot was the show's
called splitting up together it's Oliver
Hudson it's Kate Hudson's brother okay
he's a lead gen Jenna Fischer from the
office it's greater than me there's a
live other people and it's out of three
is not bad
Nicko
elders talking the microphone that arias
parting on oh I forgot
we'll have to clean it i but actually
another night though i was saying you
gotta start getting into like other more
of a spiritual way of doing your share
bro yeah I don't I don't do spiritual
what didn't see I feel like we all have
to find whatever works for it because I
I tried to meditate I'm too angry so
that means you're not Eleanor you don't
know what anger is I have anger I I get
on don't you think in a little bit of an
act your anger is it an act I can get in
a little bit I think yeah well that is
I've never met I said you know very nice
to people but if you know people frogged
me all the doors not been a calendar
what's so nice is it over there I go
she's a god yeah yeah why I can hate her
alright why but it's because I was
crossed so that's when I got to hurt me
in order for me to or you block the
driveway and then I lose my phone the
opposite way it's either a real thing or
a really shitty I just start off mean
and then someone earns their way so I
think we unique way of doing it yeah
yeah I just I try and make sure that the
bridge is burning right once someone
proves that they're good on water right
yeah right well with the bridges
completely burned down you'll rebuild it
or not most the time it's already burnt
but I am I'll try starts with a bunch of
matching logs down and see what I can do
get that bridge going you don't believe
in anything spiritual no you believe in
a God no you see there's nothing that's
God I think what about energy you don't
believe that we're all energy connected
in that way or a drink now absolutely
now the headaches yeah yeah so you're
just like self well this is it yeah
mm-hmm I think this is you know the
world we live in is our world and then
we become [ __ ] food for worms oh my
gosh I agree with you so sad but I do
agree and you do without you know I'm
terrible and I try to fight with my cell
phone
the time and I think that something
awful has to happen happen to me for it
to get positive for me to get positive
because I'm I can be very net just to
myself mostly
I have hatred too yeah I do
I wake there's a couple of comics that I
have just like you know yeah I'm in and
uh you know I'm trying to let it go but
it's like I have those things too I feel
like I'm getting better with that
I don't hate as much as I used to like I
used to just passionately hate like you
used to
I would tell you about whatever comic
pissed me off the dead yeah they're good
person let it go now just get mad like
Steve Byrne used to [ __ ] with me all the
time like one the next bed in the world
were yeah when I was younger he just
keep [ __ ] with me I'm sure he saw that
it bothered me and he thought it was
funny and we're comics and we [ __ ] with
people - it always talked to me
personally yeah yeah yeah I thought that
[ __ ] that guy you know I said so one
night and you're like well what's going
on like no [ __ ] a man you're right
he's all the nicest together oh yeah no
is it [ __ ] him and then you're like no
he's a great guy you kept telling me I'm
just like no absolutely not and then
like that lady what I see comics that I
both I like both yeah I like it one like
one comic I love hates another combat I
hate yeah and I can like you know media
bonding when I see the two guys that I
like I hate it yeah like I saw one time
and I don't know how you feel about a
trivia you feel vain yes yes how did you
why do you look at me like how do you
feel about to prove injured all right
all right good I like trivia and I saw
him and daliyah get having it out no way
I'm ever that yeah and I broke my heart
I had to talk to both of them I said I
just can't this is not going to happen
you shut it down I had to do that
specifically because I'd like both of
them and I think that who's more of a
comedy star guy Julia or trivia
there was the same nope Kirby no nope
daliyah yeah yeah you started here yeah
yeah why did you just do that well I
didn't see where your head was at like
where because the Lea was from the
minute maybe a year or two after he
started it was here I understand
Gervinho was already established yeah
you know and I and then came in
after Freddie's passing I was doing
friends here Carlos and then we yelled
at him and then this is what I respect
about Trevino everybody because he
didn't know where he is you don't know
he's in Freddy Soto's house yeah yeah
and then they kind of come they kind of
cornered him they like them yeah and
they were like hey man you're doing this
and this and this and he was like oh
okay I didn't realize yeah and even if
he did he stopped doing it
yeah yeah whether he did it on the road
and I don't know I'll never know and
care whatever he has to live with
themselves That's not me
but he he stopped doing it here and then
he started working harder and coming
here more and then really he didn't
really reinvent himself I believe that
what I don't like a oh my god yeah yeah
he kind of went from doing like almost
all Mexican act to like doing more of
the blue-collar guy which I think works
for everything yeah yeah yeah I
definitely felt he was lost when he came
like he didn't know who he was but again
he wasn't super established he was kind
of established but then he but he really
dove in and found his way here right
I've worked all has always been the
first night he dropped me out the first
day I met him he lived in Houston I
believe and he picked me up at the
airport with his brother and I didn't
know him to some the back seat and I'm
jerking off okay yeah what you do in the
back seat there's a lot I called the
Korean hello yeah you cultural let him
dancing if I don't you don't just meet
up on a stopover
yeah he don't judge it on culture but um
he pulls over on the side of a freeway
vomits kicks me out it's a good person
and he leaves me there Wow I remember
walking like three miles to get to like
a phone because there was no cell phones
done right that's when I first met him I
feel like and you can you don't hide it
my fault I shouldn't that Freddy did
some crazy [ __ ] on the road I mean they
were he opened for the three amigos tour
mmm hey history man so much history that
re all my podcast on Monday and it was
just like so much I've been here so long
wrong I know you were saying that the
other night when you brought me onstage
I'm like [ __ ] I've been here a long time
here for 14 years I can't even imagine
you're at what 20 yeah okay me too even
crazy I started 93 what year did you get
here I got I blacked out I'm sure you
did out 98 is when I legit 97 okay I
came up here and um yeah I mean it is 14
years like when I got seven yeah when I
come here it's almost it's like a part
of your house
yeah I take more time here than anywhere
he also the story can have the power do
you feel that we can go anywhere in the
building anywhere not even feel like
we're in trouble
ya know also is the house inside yeah
and no one can do that
yeah and the manager will just walk by
me and I want him to say something right
so I can have a confident you know
conversation yeah listen they double
years yeah they wouldn't yeah I love it
yeah yeah I do I mean I feel like this
is more my home than any other place in
California maybe on earth I remember
having a bad audition and I was bitching
of course while I was waiting tables in
the back and Mooney was there and he sit
there waiting to go on you know drinking
all of our boy and he used to drink the
splits I'd be like okay but he would go
through like all of them and I'm sitting
there and I'm like [ __ ] pissed crying
not crying but like bitching and I said
I'm never going to get an audition I'm
never going to book a show and he goes
oh homie you'll book a show when you
walk into an audition
the way you walk in that'll are like it
oh yeah that's it every time I go to an
audition I'm like how do I walk in me
alone what am i connect you immediately
think about it sir but I just you know
the Rope get the [ __ ] out of that seat
yeah I just guy Torry did the same thing
to me I was with the night before I
tested for MADtv I came here and this is
when he was doing in Fat Tuesday yeah
and I was like I was so nervous I mean I
was just out of my mind
yeah career changing I pretend I walked
up to guy and he was back there and he's
sitting
and I said I just don't you know and he
goes when you make love to a woman for
the first time you show her everything
like you don't do five years like my
girlfriend now I don't stick my fingers
in her butthole sure I do Mike Street
Rick's the night right you already went
around when I first hooked up with my
girlfriend I did all my muscles yeah but
he goes in comedy you have certain
things you have muscles just show them
all your muscles
did you jerk off from the bed I don't
know where go good I know like he said
it in a way where I it was clear to me
yeah I'm glad this okay I'm gonna show
this I'm not good with scientific
terminology
I'm good with mugging I'm good with like
physical stuff sure right he should show
all that and for some reason I just it
just rang with me and I went in there
and I got the show but you learned so
much here is what I'm saying yeah yeah
yeah and whether they think they're
helping you or not that some things just
resonate you just pick things up right
even if they're yelling it at you you're
like that makes sense you know like take
it all in we've seen every I think we've
seen everything here you could possibly
say my god I've seen it yeah legal
things that like you tried yeah yeah
yeah I saw a woman looking a man's
butthole on the o.r stage when I was
worried that you know I may be with a
woman yeah yeah don't judge me for how I
identified his little bear it would have
been yay if I was a man in that scenario
yeah no I would change the sign you know
I was mad because again I'm making 25 at
night they've been there all night and I
had to climb a ladder because Hatch's
work in the back door and he's too fat
to climb on a ladder a room you got to
do it one [ __ ] did you schedule the fat
guy in back doors Judea he's alive hatch
oh yeah please home I saw maybe eight
months ago
Goga doing some sketch thing but I
walked through the oh are and then Don
Barris is sitting on the the tables in
the front talking people through it with
his microphone and
there's blue iris a face buried in
Perry's ass just how about how about
five people you know probably from Iowa
or somewhere sitting the audience just
looking at a stage like what the [ __ ]
did we get ourselves into are you glad
that that elements out though what do
you mean out oh yeah I mean the other
night I'm not don't have any other night
no blue eyes almost he is dead right
yeah yeah like I think I think I'm not
here I'm not here for that stuff anymore
yeah I'm pretty much a show-up you know
what we thing like that I'm like yeah I
mean I'm okay yeah I mean why your it
was getting weird yeah well you see
people on stage that like a few people
got banned for it yeah it was weird
I remember watching people Don telling
people oh you're so beautiful I want you
to spit in my mouth and then all the
comics in the back going spit in his
mouth just a random girl finally giving
in and just spitting in his mouth and
just watching from the back penguin what
though yeah yeah it's weird it's weird
what kind of place is this is my home
but now you see II see when you look at
the audience you see like regular people
yeah yeah in many ways that's good yeah
it's good I don't you know there we used
to be a vibe of the store that it was
dangerous and seedy yeah and um there
was some shootings in the 90 like live
eyes and stuff and notice in the
building just in the Bahamas drive-by
that I know I know yeah and I'm sorry
angry that I don't really help the club
know you now people go the lineup is the
best we've ever seen anywhere on planet
Earth I think that's good yeah every
time they post on Twitter the lineup and
then you see like 20 people responding
like I gotta move that way that's the
craziest line of I've ever seen yeah my
favorite that shootout that we're
talking about it was I forget 94 and
he's somewhere around there and it was
you could get already yeah it started in
the main room a fight broke out in the
main room I believe it was two pucks
people not to park he was already gone
he was their guide entity hey Darnell
you
he was there and then they continued
outside and they were somebody was in
front of the main room door and somebody
was in the middle of Sunset Boulevard
and they were just literally shooting oh
my god and now my favorite part was I
was in the original room and everybody
was down on the floor people were
panicked you know running or whatever
the only person standing upright on the
stage was Suzanne Souter looking up
LeBeau kosuzu everyone calling what's
going on out here
oh yeah well people are cosa I don't
know I don't know if she's still alive
I just know too bad she wouldn't gunfire
it was real good looking out the window
standing straight up oh oh
Bolivia like I was like Suzanne yeah
yeah Wow I mean I when we were there
that night that night that he did that
guy died in from the alarm yeah I'm
where I'm at two years ago
no yeah did you saw the body I saw the
body I saw the I mean I hate to say it
like Valentin but it had nothing to do
with I don't even know if that guy this
is what I feel bad for because I don't
even know if that kid was at the show
that was in the manor he was on the
patio just hanging out walked up he
somebody said he walked over from the
Andaz not the Hyatt non Das and it was
he was a guy from a New York gang and
then the somebody was after him so these
guys found out that he was staying there
know that and had somebody obviously say
he just left they walked right up and it
was right to the guy and right boom boom
boom yeah walk away that those heinous
[ __ ]
guy pulled up cross exterior person from
the House of Blues no one else got hit
no strange yeah pure executing of
carries we didn't yet know I think
they're what we do right well that guy
was caught they caught him did you get
caught who did that or they did yeah
that was a 23 year old kid and they
definitely caught who did that because I
remember reading the whole article that
it was a gang thing yeah and that that
kid whomever came and did the shooting I
just remember
at right after that happened there like
they had to get all the cameras
functional so well maybe you're right
the only cameras are functioning
WorkCover booth because of the money it
was right there though yeah could see
down the step maybe that's what I'm
drinking of because I just know they put
them up on the outside everywhere so
that way basically Taylor and I believe
Matt ager were right there when it yeah
we're like whoa
and Josh Nasar hold the body that planet
totally does yeah yeah and there was
another guy Andrew the security guard I
know he was one of the dudes that was
basically sat with the dude as he was
believed oh yeah and no was it another
guy he's not a comic here just a nice
guy Justin yes our security we're
naturally right there and then a my main
concern of course because my I was with
my accent he's like don't go out there
there shoot I'm like you roses out there
yeah a lot of excess roses I was like
roses out there like I only care when
Rose isn't possibly the shooter never
know with rose roses no but you don't
know everybody I was like oh no we can
catch ya ever since you started I love
rose yeah me too that's why I was like
oh my god that's our farm park and oh
yeah she's my favorite person she lets
you make fun of her so she look like
Jean and star face that's not making fun
of but her hair was curly cheap first
star yeah yeah that kind of tone e I got
a bunch of text message that night
they're like you're not a store late and
I was like I don't hang out late anymore
what happened I was expecting like a
well done Barris made so and so II too
and so that out on stage there's like
that someone got shot to death I was
like what yeah well my thumb again glad
that I'm not yeah well then let us take
our cars out yeah I had to take a nobody
could take I was with my ex and I think
a cab all the way to Silver Lake because
he knows and tries wait so everyone left
their cars we had to they went they
everybody was a suspect they didn't know
what the hell happened because it was
warm and it was so straight this is
happening boom but it was like a dang
thing
gentle Justin said the dude walk into
the front area and like no one even
noticed them
pulled out a gun shot the guy from like
two feet away yeah like there's no way
he was missing them right deal and he
wasn't hitting anybody else alright for
what he needed and then you just kept
calling casually turned around walked
back across sunset got into his car and
just drove away because just was like I
kind of ran out in sunset and I was like
what am i doing
well the things like what I'm going to
create risk my life because this guy
just did that but yeah they said it was
so intentional there was obviously a
personal thing and not like a random
shooting but yeah but the thing I feel
bad for the show got cancelled on
Tuesdays in there and it wasn't I don't
think he was there yeah well that those
days period
[Laughter]
hey do go through the great is there
were a lot of shootings on Tuesday and
when we had the gun date nights back in
the day it was all Monday nights every
room was black my belly room everybody
everybody was here I remember giving up
a guy was like hey can you bring a
Chardonnay or Courvoisier to this guy
across the room and I did and I was like
hey so this is him sillim cell all happy
and he's like well and he started
throwing [ __ ] that fight broke out I
didn't they were gangs they were just
looking you said I said the name the guy
lost his [ __ ] mind I was like that
was an element that's kind of missing is
that we used to have a lot in the 90s he
was a black but that was 93 94 I said
like Mack oh yeah I thought they were
knee I saw excedrin but that before yeah
I'm so funny
3 Kings of Comedy yeah my first fare
ex-fiance he represented them all yeah
my brother I run by brother had just
moved up here and we saw Cedric I was
sitting with extra Paulie in the main
room the Fat Tuesday I had never seen
anyone destroy that hard in front of
that crowd oh my god unbelievable it
would kill earthquake
oh my god wait why you don't like what I
know I think earthquakes father Hank I
just heard someone told me that
earthquake can't read
that's all yeah then someone said that
earthquake was on a pilot they were
doing yeah and they were doing the table
read and every time he got to his part
everyone would just stop and he would
not say anything all right I can't oh my
god maybe I could anybody I know the
line isn't funny that was constantly no
I'm not saying that line is funny so he
would justify it why don't you do this
go up to the showrunner go I can't read
yeah
I'll memorize my lines yeah I'll have
someone working with me yeah but I guess
you know you're embarrassed and that's
exactly what I would do if I had a table
I'm being real and I can read I would
hire somebody yeah and I would memorize
every single line that I have absolutely
right and so then I know what scene it
is I know when I do that right yeah why
didn't he do that I don't know that name
I'm not giving but you know somebody
that can't read memorizes a lot yeah
can I guess yeah dice no you can read
right yeah Jewish well so get him on the
phone again away oh really
no I just hung up with ya but he would
love that
no but I'm saying like that sex good
listen you guys we're gonna say that
we're all family all right I understand
how the other person other dishes that
you were gonna say this we're gonna say
right I just want some of that I know
you Begley is it a private thing is a
private thing that you doesn't want
people to know they can't read um I
think I don't think he's led anybody
outside his team know so yeah okay
wasn't that said that's a little legit
yeah legitimate yeah absolutely that's
what y'all K let's move on yeah so yeah
I can read I've just never had anything
but I'm like uh that I needed to read
Louis I get panicked in a room like so I
do what you're saying to like if there's
a table read I try to memorize every
goddamn line because I fear from Lee
because I was a bad student
terrible student remember they would
make you read out loud oh my God my
whole body would shut down I feel like
oh good I'd have to say something out
loud yeah for this pilot I was since I
got the offer I was driving to the
network
cuz you have to do a network studio
Taylor does like the president of
everybody right and my agent calls me
and he goes you have to kill it oh yeah
I [ __ ] guess they don't you didn't
audition so this table read is your
audition right yeah you got to bring it
and I replace people
all the time people get fired yeah so
then I show up and we ended thank god
they go we're doing a pre table read and
literally the first line with this pre
table we came out like this that's it
the line is reminder you have an event
coming up today right this is how it
came out remember my mom remember mama
I couldn't even say reminder I did it I
went to my mom my mom remember and then
like the whole room shifted and they go
next door is everybody yeah you cannot
do that but you know what I did I do a
special I have a tool my life circle
every word to break it apart separately
okay I do because if I if I don't do
that sometimes I'll read it fast right
but a circle I'll put lines to separate
certain things and ideas and thoughts
that [ __ ] help me because if I
would've went remember my mama during
the [ __ ] networking I would have got
fired yeah then I canceled the whole
Sherlock is with your beta blockers yeah
you take well no beta blockers [ __ ]
take okay something right now he will
[ __ ] that table boyfriend little iris
what do you know right now because it is
[ __ ] serious on your blocker
I'm going to show you tell you here
bullet ain't no Lucy listen listen
remember the anger issues yeah come on
right now I have panic attacks okay
sometimes called being a [ __ ]
okay okay okay are weak yeah and
sometimes when I'm having a panic attack
onset it doesn't go well yeah I can
imagine that like I'll literally freeze
it's just something that like it just my
mind just starts racing and then it gets
to my hands and then I can't do it yeah
been doing I did [ __ ] Natasha and
Moshe captures so another period mm-hmm
and I had to do this a long monologue as
a pirate so they had like this dialogue
I'm not used to saying and I didn't have
a beta-blocker it was a disaster I mean
I got through it but was embarrassing
okay and it's not it's uh not it's
common amongst act it happens all the
time sure it does yeah but I asked a
girl I can't tell you it is but she's
big and she's from the store fortune no
bigger oh wow
yes and she said I told her about it
years ago she was everyone put to a
deeper beta blockers would it be I think
the beta blockers and I said Morgan
Murphy I'm not going to answer and I go
really I saw my doctor it's been a
game-changer
yeah Amy Schumer Bob you kidding me
summers not a storm you're right yeah
yeah yeah you're throwing out man all
right Colin Todd Allen Tommy told me
that that's his biggest regret was not
giving Amy Schumer stage time before she
got Billy now I didn't know she was just
another girl talking about our pusses
sounds like a Liza yeah well he might
bring Mary Lynn Rajskub here and go
Tommy
this is Maryland at least get her up on
employee and he goes I don't know her I
don't have any okay he was on and know
everything yeah Larry Sanders show yeah
mr. show yeah and every citizen of 24
yeah always so the anti girl I don't
know her yeah I prefer Ambler movie
puncher oh no and I had a turn to Mary
Lynn I go let me just talk to him for a
second yeah so she walked away and I had
a one-on-one I go bro I'm telling you
right now it sounds like you don't know
what the [ __ ] you're doing
oh yeah it was okay well I just need to
be educated okay google it I guess you
got this oh you got a flat phone it's
her employee [ __ ] spot right yeah
anything yeah I agree
when I tried to get fortune on he was
like well no one wants to look at that I
was like
my god so far tomorrow man out of our
heart begs for him to put it because the
show got nobody showed up for Adams show
on Sunday so we're like at least put her
on down here y'all want to see then she
was on Last Comic Standing all of a
sudden we need her we made one one yeah
he did have that mixi mentality of
putting people in there yeah time to fit
a category give him a Mitzi mentality
did he try though he destroyed that from
her yeah yeah yeah
Missy's bizarre yes she had a weird I
mean I don't know what your awesome what
color your aura is but yes you could not
what room Oh Jackie Graham oh god you
Jackie banana yeah she changes to Jackie
banana yeah and he changed she told him
to wear yellow he had to wear his banana
jacket yeah and it was we would keep it
in the office and then Jackie would go
on in the main room he's like I'm not
wearing that [ __ ] jacket Missy would
show up would be like where's the jacket
yelling from the back of the room and
Jackie would have to we'd have to have
everybody during it on [ __ ] stage
Jackson birdie told me put it on yeah
he's the one that got fired for his aura
not being in the right color or he said
that one summer she goes you have to
wear a purple turtleneck yeah you know
what a purple turtle like one summer Jon
goes on oh that's Louis Louis year 2000
me yeah Louie only been forming sweaters
it was like oh okay that crazy famous
bizarre not changing people Shan changed
I don't know she changed Carlos name she
just said you should change it I don't
know she picked she did she shaking
limbs he claims that she did that she
picked it yeah okay Carlos for sure she
did it but I just didn't know she picked
I liked that homage on I'm dying up here
this week yeah that's true thank you how
magical character somebody s character
name is Edgar Martinez and he gets on
her bad side and then Goldie brings him
in and it's like so Edgar Martinez has
done here at the club he's just like oh
she's like however Manny Martinez is
going to be performing regularly
Manny Martinez she's like you are wha
really be forget in yeah and I'll great
and it's oh look I love a boy he's like
so defeated Oh sad I got you got tingles
yeah in there times are hard to watch
because I'm like I also think there's a
shout out and I don't know for sure on
this but Al's character and one of the
other characters are friends but they're
[ __ ] with each other and there's a
lot of [ __ ] in each other's cars and
I kind of feel like that's kind of a
gnome on you an REI do that real it's
real yeah I mean do you think it's how
much you guys are I do I just think it's
a sea ocean already somebody already
said that too and I think it's real
because um nobody would do that it's
awesome now and and yeah it's like one
person got [ __ ] on the car well that
means the other ones going to get more
[ __ ] Nora can make me do things I know
like he came to my house Monday and he
goes he froze a Twinkie okay he goes old
times sake stick in your butthole I got
my girlfriend's here it is a shot we're
doing YouTube video I'm not doing it I'm
45 years old doing it because you have
to do what your why you have to do it
because you're a comic and you that's
who you are I'm not that yeah next thing
I know I'm sticking this thing in my
butthole and I had it halfway are you a
Twinkie and the [ __ ] kind of guy like
I might fix things in my butthole just
for a glass very good back in the day is
that where Ari got it did he steal to me
okay yeah this book takes a lot of his
[ __ ] yeah yeah Gary broke he broke
all the spokes around them yeah I used
to do at Duncan's office here when you
left and Duncan took over I used to go
to his office just stick them in my left
Cory that left give it what you know I
just Betsy made me do every job in here
I work with Scott day too
I had to answer the phones me and Steve
more I was the stories I tell as always
at your tell corner I was never the
telling coordinator never ever won those
the stories our time I know those are
sad my princess my comedy straight
trying to say they're incest Cory you
didn't have you didn't have power none
nope what what kind of power would I
have cuz I was your hire anybody who
went well that kind of power is very
defensive right now
asking you a question yeah I can't yet
we have higher fired you know how do you
think he'll be able to ear though I
would never hear the thing everybody
that went to MIT see with some kind of
bizarre story whatever it would be
however you were Bobby Shropshire
however you say that Bolivia those
[ __ ] weirdos that used to get in her
ear say all this [ __ ] try to get
everybody to know yeah all the whistles
I was like wait Cynthia never did that
but yes she does the whistle she they
would get mitts easier I'm a guy girl
whoever it was and then they would wind
up get fired I was here for 12 years
yeah I never [ __ ] did that because
she would immediately turn on you she we
were trying to [ __ ] somebody else she
would [ __ ] you - you know sometimes like
Melinda almost got a lot of my staff
fired almost but then I had to be like
Belinda I'm gonna [ __ ] kill you
she stopped and then I forget what she
did I never had a go-to Michie I never
to say anything she did something
immense he got rid of her and I can't
remember what it was but it was the
easiest way just wait and let them [ __ ]
it we always waited it out rules don't
really apply to her I was when I was a
day I'm still in a but mid-sea fired a
lot of people avoid back in the day oh
my god she hired a lot of people
everyone everywhere and I had a
resentment so I went to my a sponsor his
name was will at the time and I go will
I have this resentment toward the
teacher who are right because while
you're gonna have to write a step about
it you have to do an inventory right and
so I had to write in a how my what my
resentment is how I feel about it and
all that and then he says you're gonna
have to confront her with this
resentment how would be fun and I go I
look at him I go that works in every job
maybe on planet Earth except there's a
lot of terrible puns you know looking
away are you saying I represented too
small well then you're I'll never see
you again
fine now whatever that would be it yeah
I took her I brought her home from the
hospital I put her in bed I thought I
did everything right I went home to take
a shower yeah
ah there was a knock on the door it was
the police
she called the police on me what power I
have I know I go what the [ __ ] what did
I do
yeah I was lost and here she was having
an episode early stages of dementia and
she went to get up and she went to get
the phone and it was a fax machine and
she pulled in everything fell and she
said I left her there for dead I tried
to kill her I got the cops to my house
oh my really was the what happened well
I was at work I'm calling Polly I'm like
any like what happened
yeah I do everything you told me is a
[ __ ] crime right I mean I'm sure time
I didn't like you I would have loved
that so I wouldn't he decided I sort of
realized oh [ __ ]
I need another there were so many times
when I was about to be fired it was only
one other person in the since 93 that
I've been here that I got a fight with
his name was also Bobby maybe it's the
name even though I love my little
brother grease grease [ __ ] yeah he's a
tree called Nancy and because I don't
know why you didn't like me I don't know
what the [ __ ] happened maybe because we
wouldn't listen to him sometimes but
that's mostly what we would do you
always want the manager he always wanted
to act like he was like third in line
what I don't like do you revine all the
language I was like what are you doing
taking this any would bias roses and
[ __ ] and whoever had the highest sound
give him roses and I'm like I don't like
flowers don't get me talking about and
so I he drove me nuts he called mitzi
until Missy that me and steve Schirripa
were robbing the place
oh I was like omits he's like him and
she was mad at Schirripa because
reported he didn't work here no but
Schirripa Mitzie said that when she went
to the riviera to see Pauly you know he
gave me a room we put me in a [ __ ]
Murphy bed okay
I only did it oh my god like it was a
PETA [ __ ] so she was already angry at
Schirripa
so Bobby new sheriff and I were good
friends because I used to book comics
form you know like look whatever so I
don't know did you go
that is teacher Riviera he was also on
he was also on that show
oh yeah Sopranos never watch okay well
anyway I cast this over I believe in God
or watch this channel yeah I could
afford HBO like Rocky I can't talk
numbers
you don't like rocky along with a whole
movie it's so real right what do you
like [ __ ] yes no Nestle
I like Shawshank Redemption oh yeah you
like Evergreen movies like Braveheart
Braveheart everyone loved watches over
again
how dare you not like Rocky we will
select you like that it was okay
Raging Bull yeah raging bulls good Axl
who's in it Robert De Niro and who else
I don't know Robert De Niro so Joe Pesci
job passing you never finished she's
pretty an old it was like I said it's so
annoying in that perfect but he's
terrific he plays yeah he's playing his
part dad that weekend is public good
weekend I got cat I had passed because
that was i okay Paulie when in Libya or
whether she was there because that
reminded me that something about the
bedding I think she could you ain't
about it yuria yeah [ __ ] Murphy but
she came out to me that night what
scenarios the one that comes down oh he
did not she was just pissed but what
afterward when I saw when I opened for
it I was a kid I was 24 yeah so I was
working at a restaurant San Diego he
flies me over there and I just remember
being in his room but then he was so big
at the time he was at the top of the rib
on this like it was a grand piano and
this oh yeah it's two floors right Laura
to give us them right and it was [ __ ]
beautiful
yeah and we're sitting there and all
these [ __ ] hot chicks something you
wouldn't think with in the ribs that's
how bad that's how about it's amazing
yeah okay and the Liberata [ __ ]
that's it
like if you walk you know polished hall
at night Winky no sorry good and I
remember going oh this is what
they get you yeah it doesn't no no I get
to be I've never seen it anything like
that room with my ex-fiance but because
he's the don't got the [ __ ] this
forever episode I am sorry
Mario's a lot of ex-fiance's the only
two ex-fiance's Bobby Bobby the grease
he was he was always kind of about noise
I love it I love Pauly's guys out him
yeah rod Bobby to me
yeah to me Bobby was part of the Dean 15
point but when we were he was not like
he was you just would always tell us
about what he used to do but he didn't
do any more terrific handyman though by
the way excellent I'm serious like he
did all those chairs oh he did all you
Reeve buying or whatever it's called
reupholstered stuff here he I was in the
hole for a week in one time I guess me
and Freddie Lockhart and we're sitting
in the condo and we just hear hey comedy
star to someone yelling outside we're
sitting in the condo I'm like [ __ ] is
that
no no maybe it's a fan so I go out and I
look out on the balcony
grease is just standing down on the
[ __ ] grass area there he's like oh
hey Dane Grom I'm like what's up man he
was like hey my I'm down here with my
family can I come hang out for a couple
of minutes just he did go he did it
right so we pulled the code he comes up
loved his wife by the way didn't get to
meet any of them it's just him he was
basically ditching his family and he
wanted to get high so I smoked him out
and I got him so [ __ ] high like we
just kept making him smoke because I was
like well [ __ ] if he's gonna come crash
our weekend we're going to make him get
really hot suddenly got him super high
and we were going to go do something and
we're like we're going to go he's like I
don't think I could face my family do
you guys care if I just hang here you're
like oh do what you got man we left like
three hours came back still just sitting
there oh my I felt great that was well
as things from again I got good pot this
seems good this feels real good
oh but warlock you like warlock and I
got ya back I was on the road with Polly
ones best breath in the business he's
like a dragon's prize and
girl oh so I love well these are men
college girls right after the show goes
we went to hook up with you and Polly
party right so these two girls you know
they they you know finish me and Paul
you know what they do we're not in the
talent but while you're skating Rogers
in the room yeah well you know and he's
just watching and these two young girls
and then after we're done Holy Ghost
what about hand just their faces
imagine finishing name Paul okay just
hold you when I but that was fine and
then you have to go to that mythological
creature I mean golly well Roger a few
girls have to blow Roger dude I was so
sad an amazing special best day of
warlocks alive Oh amazing it's so scary
I know I love Warlow like Paula Deen's
15 is different than paulie's yeah some
of them trickled over what's teen 15 the
Deen 15 was a crew for a while being
always had like a crew of people that
were here that served no purpose other
than their friends would be for parents
parents 90 and Jerry Kennedy yeah there
are they can't what yeah yeah Jill for
sure that guy who wrote Kingsley I think
his name is guy with the big brother
where screenplay ever it was Lord Dean
gives me the screenplays like Braille
reasons Kingsley wrote it it's a hundred
in like 40 pages we're talking like a 20
hour 20 minute movie Gone with the Wind
is a vamp a skateboarding vampire movie
I remember that yeah yeah and that [ __ ]
ends at page 220 or 240 whatever was it
ends
trap door opens the main character falls
down story in the shallow water to be
continued
I was like no you to be continued to
some you said I want you in it to me yes
I kind of audition yeah
I'm gonna screw it back to the exactly
the worst script I've ever read yo bro
it makes no sense but I'm so happy you
let me read it yeah it was awful so
those the guys look guys payment he
looked at Mindy Danny
Oh that'll I all Adam I saw him at a
NACA conference yeah yeah how was that
he was like getting dates yeah I
remember her telling me about it he's
ever women from telling me I'm getting
booked a dominant world's fastest
painter bro on the College of yawning
being like oh my god but they were
always here they were like people know
you like mom with Dean's they're here
wow he originally was beam dozen but
then he kept adding people like a white
dragon yeah 82 mass bro dude a man
what'd you say the math you saying man
always giving me stones I don't know
what number four was like thank you and
I just welcome home
hey hey Rick what do you think about
this art like you just poured bleach
black t-shirt I bet you would amass bro
man I don't think that are they applies
here I remember yeah there's a whole
crew of them like I can't even think of
half of like a Morgan Amina when you did
the Riviera that's how you got showcase
here like yeah I don't have I was at a I
was in La Jolla did you do the big room
upstairs in the room it was like three
thousand six yeah and I was working the
door La Hoya I was at a waiting job it
wasn't enough no one knew me yeah I was
at an open mic in La Jolla and Paulie we
happened to be there and he came up to
us did you're weird you don't have jokes
but there something weird about you like
that's how he perfect like all right
he's like I want you to open for me at
the rim
it's basically what happened so I go oh
you know fly me there how do I get there
but that's okay I said oh I don't know
like I guess there what's the process if
you're a walking path like this is like
oh you got me a ticket I flew out there
and
I did the show I didn't know really I
heard of mrs. mom but I didn't know she
was there but then at that party
afterwards
mmm she just walked up to me I'm ed C
and this is when she was very cognitive
and clear I mean she was you know it's
he sure you're still driving back then
yeah and she's like you're irregular
damn and it so your showcase was at the
rib yeah well I mean you could do no
wrong in front of his crowd yeah and
also at that time five minutes right
like I would like to warm up right all
right
so it's like it was a it was a gift yeah
although Steve Ari and Steve Rannazzisi
Simone and Ari all gotten in trouble for
opening for Pauly yeah that's right oh
they did yeah Mitch he got rid of unpaid
regulars or not regulars because they
opened for and she didn't approve oh
really at the seasonal improv friend and
I think I think it was the Macondo
of they were opening for Pauly on the
show that sandy booked yeah her kids
therefore you're turning your back on me
owes me four grand sandy shore a big
surprise there was a time when like she
was like I don't know what how she was
living she was living in San Diego yeah
she was living in one of the condos for
a while and she would like happy with
old like little tin foil has to
communicate with aliens in the back her
dog where I guess she was like to call
me girl I need money I can't eat and I'd
have to go to the Western Union and send
her money
Wow well it's been a moment no can I ask
you why would you do I mean like because
still because because are you that close
Holly brought me to the rib the family
basically you know how you started got
me started like were you closer with
sent like I was from San Diego I would
see her more all God again okay so it's
like yeah I just got with my landlord
down there so I mean I I was I'm
involved with the family at that time
yeah I know everybody right and because
she's a short store sure I play at the
store I just felt obligated
Wow even though your son's a million
your brother's a millionaire yes a mom
million Molly I would have called well
Missy Walter brother : same it was
Amelia here she had so much money out
mortgage every house a shame or
something but like I would just go to
Western Union and do it no it's very not
very nice I stopped doing it I did
that's the third time I'm not doing
anymore I can't do it I mean that did a
lot of comics here it may have cut her
off as well so they hang better off that
when I first found out of her existence
that was the story was she's basically
cut off out of the family
yeah she had taken so much from everyone
at that point she's doing comedy classes
don't I think so yeah and then she put
this book out where she said she was
engaged or she was married to dice for
five years or engaged to die something
for five years so we were here one night
and sandy was here and Andrew goes hey
we got your book ha ha ha ha ha not
really you know 5 years you know we went
out and he goes here 5 months
I thought you the wicker chair and you
broke up with me oh wow thought that
would really help was breaking out hook
up with me too - no no but everybody
thinks yeah that was a rumor
Mindy really wanted sandy and Andrew to
work out like she want them to marry
like one hit she was like this would be
perfect could take her away this would
solve my problem of forever right
so if she used to tell me that all the
time this is way before I was wish you a
trifecta
Sandy's adorable in the eighties yeah I
mean she got nothing I knew her when she
was Francesca Hilton yes young like my
loony yeah she's definitely yeah I only
met her was a nice lady I just want to
listen get mad she but hey she was a
little loony here yes usually she will
get her things like I would be like
Mitzi maybe you should think about this
like with certain things with Sandy you
know I think it would be cool to have
her class you know like because Mitch
even know you know like yeah let's do
this let her class come in no yeah and
whatever like she would just be mad at
her for the mall
then you let her sit on it and then
she'd come back yeah if they're letting
Greg Dean showcase up here as well did
you get mad at Plan B for anything and
then just [ __ ]
well whatever always have stories like
she tried to take the club in Hawaii for
her own no no the fight was over her
filming Louie Anderson and that was it
well that was the only she's Lilly said
don't fail me she killed it
Mitzi found out she got pissed so she
went after sandy and then she made all
the comics turn on her so then she
started wearing tinfoil hats ah smart
that's what happened so dice never did
that
now did Shubert eat Mitzi's [ __ ] I keep
hoping it'll make I ate it definitely
dated Mitzi fry no time yeah she's your
dude that's amazing yeah but he didn't
eat it yeah he definitely ate it just
hang out yeah yeah you mean why do you
think he live it was a violent violent
pussy-eating session
whoa what one Thanksgiving I was at
Polly's house Mitzi Mitzi had her feet
on the table my I'm eating cold turkey
oh my god
and I hear this ah right it's like when
I look over and her nails are just on
the [ __ ] table hitting like you know
oh oh yeah I think when I was like I
can't eat this if I thought it was rich
so gross if I saw nails clacking on a
table yeah curled over the toes yeah
oh wait till she started laughing yeah
right what we brought crews Freddie
daughter over she was real little after
we brought her over to show Mitzi and
like we're playing we're sitting with
Mitzi and Corey's like making creme you
know and she wanted to go like our hands
shook yeah and she went like right near
her face and her nails like seven inches
too long and it just got Freddie's like
my baby's eyes
we were tonight uh so for like munch we
would do that oh my baby died yeah she's
like a what the Mitzi I knew the first
couple times no matter if she was kinda
together and after that she just
basically seemed like a scary like
Disney villain and towards the end what
she's to come it was different solitude
whether you know I used to come here
yeah wait like sixty pounds year ago
since 42 scarves yeah we should be right
the mayor better hurry up like she was
like a Cheerios janitor clowns yeah yeah
yeah and she was to show up and mumbling
it's just yeah you shall fabric
trembling yeah
[ __ ] relative village I'm not laughing
at her tremors I'm laughing at the fact
that lemon would do her hair and really
she would always say married in my hair
and I just look at it like holy [ __ ]
that's paralyzed so he literally just
like a loose strand taking say that are
correct like Bill Murray my hand is
trackage a hair dressing play she sold
you made millions and millions of
dollars yes she was like a really
amazing hair by lemare not by what
happened diddly don't know so what
happened to her
would happen to Cheryl that daddy oh I
don't know Cheryl so around I think she
I don't know yeah she moved she said to
Berkeley no no she was very funny
oh yeah lady from Boston she's married
to a woman they have I think they
adopted a little girl and they were
doing a reality cooking show laughs I
spoke to her just a through Facebook
little Negron a regular golden glimmer
mustard yeah googled urkesh July yeah
she was a regular she was frightening is
what you another one she try and be with
her candy or it was like Roxy city [ __ ]
in rugby in a wheelchair rail near
cereal yeah eat my ass through stage
time on the open mic one night here how
back oh did she get any stage yeah yeah
I got a three minutes so this is
disgusting remember wheels telling us
that we're all like whoo I see eight
nine we're like friends of jail like ten
times so she wouldn't get attacked here
and then if he let her I don't know how
but it was a Danish and O'Neill yeah
time yes really tough time to host with
those guys heckling yeah and maybe re
maybe Skippy
I forget who else I don't know if you
were part of it okay good I didn't know
if I could sorry onto the bus but they
just went up and ripped the [ __ ] out of
her every time they brought her out is
everybody going wheels your crew
everybody doing wheels or she was she
would she would get nasty with them
first and then you know I you know who I
am that kind of thing yeah I thought
they would come they were retaliating
yeah and then as we just were causing
them okay maybe I'm not gonna act like
we were only fighting back sometimes it
was just like [ __ ] this let me just
[ __ ] start this fire but right with
our face well she she had like it was
the worst she was like Dagmar so like
don't act like you're [ __ ] yeah like
the gift to comedy and ha it's those
elements I'm glad I mean I hate to say
it well if she ran out of here I know
but still it's there isn't there now
it's it's a little bit harder to get up
on stage yeah right here thank God thank
God right and it's like you have to
really actually work harder and yeah but
that's what we were saying early in the
beginning like it's different I don't
know if it's good or bad but I think
it's none of that 100% again 100 cent
much better yeah I agree
I definitely I don't get as many spots
and I'm fine with it
sure I didn't have one deny it it's hard
you could drive in you see the lineup
you don't go up yeah it's hard it is but
I've accepted it
I have I have I it's not it's not like
I'm resentful at me but I get it
just doesn't feel good yeah yeah right
but you know you want to go up every
night yeah of course yeah but it's good
for the club I mean there was a time
when polly was like and i can into a
strip club
yeah yeah yeah you're right now you're
like oh you're like oh yeah we're like
oh yeah I could go into a home keep up
the pulse is like I think is like where
am I going to go they closed exactly
this is the only I know where we go
it was the only thing I know in LA yes
leave me tour the building down and just
turned it into a parking lot then I
would just have to hang out at the
parking lot four nights a week like I
wouldn't know where to call them I went
down sunset so that all my jealousy is
so sad to just go to the superior let's
go pay $59 to hang out on that lot so
hope Mickey ear Johnny's out show up and
talk to me did I tell you about the time
I parked a car for Kenny Loggins shot
Johnny's at but please don't leave me
alone did you ever think about a time
when it's going to inevitably happen
when I'm gonna get the call
you just don't call it anymore yeah I
can that scares me I don't get sex over
that yeah I used to have it with waiting
tables and now I have it with this yeah
gonna happen one day where I'm gonna be
like getting that call like oh like you
have nowhere to go
yeah again just don't have spots for you
why watch me I'm dying up here the scene
with Judi golden yeah was unbearable I I
found it literally really hard to watch
but that's where we it's what happens
yeah in evitable
that's all they didn't happen to some
though all my wrong job but now my rare
stays relevant exactly what I'm saying
yeah it's like him Argus we get yeah
that's not that's progress he [ __ ] so
good thirty years can go by and he still
gets prime spot baby boomer is kind of a
master [ __ ] there's a smile scope it was
me all he's doing a deal to reduce sirs
references that no one saw the film in
the new movie the Hitler say whatever
that is no one knows what it is yeah no
believe me yeah
marv that when argos called me a year
ago is like rich a new document which
yes
intro to me you seen in him on color
television
why Oh what did he say I had a friend
who's at the show on Friday night and he
said that one of the young guys busted
my balls pretty good and I wanted to
make sure it was you and if it was you
that we don't have any real beef you're
just busting my balls the way you always
do so I said that to you yeah I was like
it was me and I was just I was joking
Jomon tell me what you said oh did you
really say that yeah yeah I said well I
said that you used to [ __ ] the owner and
your [ __ ] are so good that you still
get spots 30 years later yeah well
that's the truth and then I said I said
you know I said you're you're the best
social studies teacher doing comedy to
say okay great well I just want to make
sure that we're good I didn't want oh
nothing yeah nana is a warrior yeah and
she did get me sober he was one of those
guys really yeah I knew where to go
meetings and stuff like that he was all
very helpful so when I had to stop
drinking he pulled me aside several
times and like really pushed I'm like no
I'm gonna I'm gonna I don't need it he's
like I think you should do it I said you
know I'm meeting my traffic oh my
choices are quit drinking or die so I'm
pretty good on not drink I just picked
something to you though yeah they help
with the sharing it's not it's not even
that it helps with your whole life in
terms of like walking through fear and
letting things go and taking action and
it's like a it's a foundation to live
your life I know you're not ever gonna
do it yeah you're not you're not but you
I don't go to meetings because they tell
me I have to yeah I do it because it
helps my life out on so many different
levels now check your hand out having
fellowship right and then just letting
things go
and also visualizing things and
manifesting things all that stuff is
like stuff that I really rely on I wish
that you would be able to do it well
that's fine
but I just it would make I believe in my
opinion is that your life better it
might be better for your family right
because you'll become happier I believe
but that's just my opinion
yeah okay you're not gonna doing this
fine yeah I did na and I I remember
getting so annoyed in there but then I
started like letting it in and just
chilling and then eventually I just
stopped going yeah but at first I was
like this is [ __ ] like yet in there
are aspects of it that is really weird
and and people that aren't doing it
right but you know I've been sober for
15 years I was sober for 12 before that
and I've seen the magic happen yeah and
the reason why I'm still sober and I'm
still an advocate of it is because I
know that everything that I have in my
life from the shows that I'm on to my
management I'm with CA everything that I
have is because of that yes I'm funny I
have the talent so do you okay I'm down
right but but you don't saying okay
you're I'm just trying to yeah just you
know show you a different path brother
yeah but you're just so [ __ ] look at
you stubborn [ __ ] man yeah I mean that's
like crazy Irish team yeah it is yeah
now yeah I don't know I mean I don't
have any sort of I mean I don't have any
urges to get intoxicated I understand
that but not about that it's not about
not using my problem would be listening
to someone tell me about how I need to
be more positive that's not what it is
though what is this is is that our
suffering comes from thinking about
ourselves in our lives right okay and
basically what it is is getting out of
your
and helping other people no one do that
okay I'm just saying but that in the
Bible in any kind of religious context
any kind of spiritual moment that's
always the foundation and sure and
that's these two drugs in the 1930s who
was a doctor when it was a money guy he
was a stock market guy they couldn't do
they got together one day and they
realized together if they just went out
and helped people they just didn't they
lost desire and it changed their lives
and I'm just saying that's what it is I
find I can touch it no I know
wait can I say this about Rick though
with the drinking I feel like Rick
didn't drink to repress or hold like you
know sometimes people drink to get out
of themselves
Rick truly drank to have fun and then it
started getting in the way of Eleanor
drinking is a problem it's all welcome
no I know but in the way every in every
case he's got their biddies and that
right and have it yeah but so like oh
I'll be having fun I know that guys I
know all so what you're saying is is
that what you're saying is but usually
so smoke pot right nothing done anything
body and I think for four years right I
haven't had a drink in six years I
haven't smoked pot in four years it
wasn't impeding his life it was just I
mean it was sucking up literally inside
his body right so it's a difference when
you hit a bottom
I guess his bottom was there's our title
man I wish I woulda gotten diabetes
would have been so much easier yeah yeah
I get what you're said what you're
saying is is that but when you take away
the drinking and the end of marijuana
and all that stuff right you don't think
about it I know now I mean I did when I
when I first do you find yourself more
miserable now we're happier uh I would I
would say that I'm I'm I I'm more aware
of how things irritate me right more
aware of why so many things right that
you know those awarenesses that you have
about your character defects right sure
if you see you acknowledge them but
there are ways to deal with them
right to get through them and to improve
upon them to get rid of them yeah right
but what you're doing is this is my
opinion again is that I'm sorry this is
not funny but I just don't where you do
it it goes hi to me ina and the hell or
I'm just trying to I just want to just
need the second give me in a second all
right dad arm you know you just want to
think the point of life is to improve
you know what you know what Socrates
said a life not self examined is a life
not worth living
sure right so it's about looking inside
dealing with our insides or character
defects or our problems and to be able
to like grow I think virtually and
physically and mentally and all that
sometimes I think naturally I'm a angry
person and I feel like when I quit
smoking pot
my uh my comedy improved greatly because
I'm it's real ER yeah I became more of
who I actually am whereas when I smoked
pot I did things that bothered me I
didn't I just didn't care because I was
of a stone so I was like yeah my
career's not going great whatever it is
but whatever I'm buzzing so who gives a
[ __ ] and then once I stopped for a while
the quitting drinking was tough for like
a week for me and then it was just like
whatever I don't need that quitting
smoking pot was tougher because I really
enjoyed it
and there's something I could do during
the day sometimes whatever wasn't and
I'm like comedy like the first month
after I quit smoking pot was super angry
mmm it was just I was just so mad I
would yell at people and it went over
well surprisingly then I get offstage I
was just like yeah I damn I got some
problems yeah but now I think my comedy
is great it's I think the right level of
anger I don't think that I should I
don't I don't think I should be just you
know in general happy I don't think
that's the way I am oh okay like I I
thought yeah there's someone else Oh
parts of my life that I love I've never
been happier with there than I encourage
it with your kid and my kid my wife yeah
I like I love a good portion of my life
there's just things that still anger me
there's going to go on in the world I
think or [ __ ]
yeah and it's what I do like it's not
gonna change you know I mean yeah the
main kind no matter what it is about me
there's just there's just things that I
can't stand I don't I don't like the way
people think kind of like the fact that
some people are allowed to have opinions
on things
mm-hmm I'm the reason why I'm just
saying these things in general toward
you I wouldn't give a [ __ ]
yeah I didn't give a [ __ ] a couple of
months ago sure I can [ __ ] now
because of the fact that when I saw you
perform a couple of months ago it I had
a revelation about you and the
revelation was oh this guy is really
good yeah
he's so no I know I'm not saying it just
to say it it was a rebel it was an
awakening right it was a spirited
awakening where I turned to somebody and
I went Jesus whoa Wow yeah right and to
see where you're at doesn't make any
sense to me
all right so now what I do is go what is
he doing in his life in worry when it
comes to like networking or get you
business or yeah and what I'm saying
that's the problem
yeah right you're not sucking dick Leo's
on email my point though is is that so
now that's why I'm it does investment
yeah because I want to go what can we do
right to get you so that you're
optimistic and proactive and out there
and getting [ __ ] done yeah okay but
apparently there's nothing we can do so
that's a [ __ ] how about have the the CAA
or if managers come see them I would
yeah but the thing is is that they want
you to have something it's not that it's
the thing okay and with you is a
specific there's a thing that works
against you but I think then people
would say this before I saw you and I go
yeah yeah that's it which is the crowd
work yeah yeah but then I'm watching you
I got what these are just you're just
taking out setups yeah you have the
punchlines right you're just taking away
you know some of the ways of delivering
yeah right they're in a different way
yeah so we you know we could rewrite it
a little bit to have it more in the
language of traditional stand-up yeah
sometimes I don't even not occur not so
if it's not that yeah if it's not that
it's something you're doing outside of
that yeah okay yeah I don't network
that's I mean dude let me say something
right now Patricia O'Neill told me once
he goes name-dropper no no this is
really I'm not yeah yeah I'm really not
I guess I would have died
so I told me what I was doing open
Anthony right and he looks at me he goes
do we just Auto egos you and I are the
same I go why you and I are horrible
because I've seen you at socializing and
networking yeah which is true I'm a
comic I love traditional comic and I
that's true I'm not like I've seen dr.
ken Jeong in party situations he's so
likable and lovable I'm in the corner of
the room I'm so I want to figure out how
the [ __ ] to get out of that yeah my same
right so but I had to that you need to
survive yeah right so now if I get a job
I show up early I'm so positive I don't
want to be I wait I don't feel like
you're going a guy wanted yeah when I
gain I'm gonna go with the [ __ ] is this
alright yeah I mean but I'm extremely
grateful positive when I go into
auditions I have a positive attitude you
know if it doesn't work it doesn't well
you had to change the way I look at the
world you're right because I know that I
have the skills to do it that's not the
[ __ ] point
that's not the problem you're the
problem you isn't that the problem with
you is is that you look at you and
there's like a [ __ ] you know Saruman
you know means like it's dark yeah I'm a
dark human right and you we don't have
to be because you have elements in your
life right and that make you know yes it
doesn't make him who he is no it doesn't
I mean on stage that's one thing okay I
mean like jazel neck is like that yeah
he's just a dark dude but obviously he's
not to me he's very playful um he worked
on two but yeah but he's doing it too I
know that's exactly what he's yeah yeah
there's a push to get there I trust me
do not easy I have to push to do it when
they go when they go there is a wrap
party I don't give a [ __ ] yeah when I go
sure and I wear that I buy the suit I
hold hands with my [ __ ] girlfriend
wait and I shake hands you know I do I
would do that [ __ ] I know but I'm just
saying I have to force myself to do it
Yeah right you have to force yourself to
try to change that about yourself I
believe like if you if I'm wrong I'm
wrong nobody even like going out and
networking it's hard like there was a
night I remember I did it like three
nights in a row
and I'm terrible at bragging on myself
like I go to a party but like you got a
Syrian Grimm you got to see Bobby Lee
you maybe never bother have you got a
safe you never had anybody but you know
what I'm saying like also it they'll say
we're looking for female comics and I'll
rattle off 15 names and none of them are
mine yeah so I have to stop doing that
right and I did that there was three
nights in a row I literally gave myself
the stomach flu that's how bad it was
what did we say I for three nights in a
row bragged on me yeah trying to try to
excel you tell me yeah and I woke up
with a stomach flu it's so hard I know I
can't do it have you been anywhere where
they're asking for white male yes Holly
I'm telling you we need it I'm always
doing that all right I think I got a log
that's a long time yeah we did
how long did we do Rick I'm sorry we are
I think we're at an hour and a half yeah
our 25 hour and a half of a no it wasn't
all the air I you know I always did that
honestly said because of what I what I
just know I I if you were a con man
named but like Jonah if you were gonna
name in but there's another guy let me
guess it's no okay but there's a guy who
is very funny mm-hmm he's angry yeah he
causes rifts and I know that he is he
had trouble with addiction if I I would
if he that I'd be asked me what do I do
I would tell him but we don't even have
a communicate we doing volunteer like
each other right I mean he doesn't like
me whatever right so it's like feel like
that happens a lot yeah but I want to
tell him that those things but I don't
have and even if we were in this you'd
have to ask me right with you I want to
throw it out and go now you're not that
bad you know you're completely different
class at him but my point is is that I'm
yeah I listen I'm trying to figure it
out having a kid who's definitely
motivated me more to be like I gotta go
I gotta figure out how to do this [ __ ] I
just I just read a book it is a book
it's a simple book book which one am I
The Four Agreements oh it's very simple
it's 100 pages okay
it's it's this small it's just four
rules that you have to abide by that's
gonna help your life out it's easy rules
okay it's being impeccable with your
word what is what happen again The Four
Agreements is by Miguel Ruiz in oral
book you can get an audio book you know
what sometimes that what I'll do is I'll
take that audio book and just listen to
it there's really not a lot of God in it
it's just just you know Jackson Perdue
is the one that Jack Perdue yeah we
refer advantage of that book but my
point is is that just fry hi
did we can't do it like that is that the
green goodbye like so I'm gonna tell you
I'm going to plug something got a
podcast but I have a testing others on
your [ __ ]
called Tiger belly with my girlfriend
yes yeah and then I'm on a show called
what would Diplo do and it's August 3rd
on Vice land we did six episodes that's
great with me and james van der beek
and tomorrow neighbors of the night oh
yeah okay yeah and he plays Diplo to DJ
I play his manager and it's a first
scripted show okay and then I'm on an
ABC show called I'm splitting up
together and it's with me and Jenna
Fischer
I'll read ten and I most want love but
you know things out Thank You Bobbie Lee
thank you for joining the comedy circuit
Robert Lee Robert Lee I remember him
thanks for tuning in guys
I'm braking group thank you for
listening
I'm Eleanor Kerrigan and that was Rick
ever telling The Comedy Store does a
show while you can
thank you Scott
[Applause]